Nèm mình xin thằng tắm năm 2018, trên cao tốc ở tình nươi, đây loàn.
Trung Quốc sẽ ra vụ vào trạm nhảy giữ xe văn, năm tài sế điều khiển chở theo ba hành khách và chức tés la so một lữ tài sế cầm lại.
Cả hai tài sế xuống xe đứng gần hai xe để cho đổi vụ việc.
Lúc này, một chức khổ vô vô dọn lữ tài sế cầm lại tông thằng vào chức xe văn.
Hầu qua, bán người thịt mạng, uống tài sế xe văn, một lữ hình khách trên xe và tài sế chức tés la,
lực lựng lựng năng khuyên kháo, khi phương tỉnh gặp sự cố trên đường cao tốc,
người điều khiển cân nhé trong đưa xe và lan dừng khình khách hoặc vị trí an toàn nếu phương tỉnh vẫn còn khả năng zí chuyển.
Bất ngay đàn kánh báo nguy hiểm, đã tiếp bị hoặc biển kánh báo phía sau xe.
Lưa toàn bộ vụ vụ trí xe xe ra khỏi phương tỉnh và zí chuyển đến vị trí an toàn phía ngoài dài hộ lan hoặc khu vực bảo vệ.
Lần thơ liên hiện ngày lựng lựng lựng lựng năng hoặc liên vị còn li tính đường để được khổ chở,
tự đối không đứng hoặc đi lại chiếc phần đường xe trạng.